Good morning, Hank. It's Sunday.
Hank, as you know last week my book
"Paper Towns" won an Edgar Award.
An award given out by the mystery writers of
America to the best mystery novels of the year.
Hank, this means that I am now the proud
owner of a bust of Edgar Allan Poe.
Which begs a question:
What could you do with a Poe bust?
You could put him on your head.
You could dress him up as a sailor?
No, no, you can't actually.
He's already dressed up as a sailor.
What could you do with a Poe bust?
You could play Wii with him?
Oh! You just got Edgar Allan Pwned!
What could you do with a Poe bust?
You could replace your face.
My Edgar, what lovely puff you have.
What could you do with a Poe bust?
You could make them wear sunglasses.
Honestly, in terms of face-to-sunglasses ratio
Edgar looks more normal right now
than your average Olsen twin.
What could you do with a Poe bust?
You could play dress-up with a bust of Edgar Allan Poe.
You can put it on your shoulder
and see if it'll say nevermore.
Poe Bust: Nevermore
Oh wow.
It talks.
Edgar Allan Poe, you have a funny voice.
What could you do with a Poe bust?
You could waterboard him.
I'm gonna ask you one last time, Edgar.
What does the raven symbolize?
Oh, you're not gonna. You're not gonna talk?
Yeah, you're gonna talk.
What could you do with a Poe bust?
You can use a Poe bust as fitness equipment.
He could be your garden gnome.
What could you do with a Poe bust?
Actually, I think I'll just keep him on the mantel.
Poe Bust: Oh P/S Australian nerdfighters,
look in the sidebar
for some information about
upcoming events with John.